if I was starting a YouTube channel from
scratch this is exactly what I would do
it's super powerful for someone who
wants to make YouTube their job
full-time living a lot of people say
like ranking's dead I strongly disagree
with that YouTube themselves said if you
do YouTube right and if you do video
ranking Academy right I've got videos
that are over 10 years old that are
still getting views in this episode it's
actually part two of us going through
our 7R system that we use here at think
media to consistently get views get
subscribers and grow on YouTube so
definitely check out part one where
you're gonna get the first couple R's in
the system but now let's get into part
two where we're going to keep the
conversation going
so someone hits record uh and maybe
they've already been hitting record and
now they're going to release which is
number four release I'd love to hear
kind of some of the best practices here
for releasing your content specifically
you know this year you know there is
some stuff changing with the algorithm
with tags there's shorts
um and I know that's a different release
strategy but let's talk about
um what are some of the best practices
right now for when you actually are
uploading to YouTube yeah the checklist
here is
on record if you made your outline in
research you recorded you shot
everything now we're also assuming you
may not have edited you might have also
Gone live or you may have just recorded
it straight through and you're uploading
a 10 minute video but or you've edited
did the video and you've exported it and
uploaded it now it's sitting there so
release would be also the process of
preparing it for publication preparing
it for putting it out in the world so
you want to make sure you get your title
on there your description your tags your
it could be hashtags end cards add it to
a playlist
prepare all of those optimized details
put an end card on there and anything
that you've thought through in regards
to that release could also of course
include time of upload people get stuck
on these things YouTube themselves said
like if you do YouTube right and if you
do video ranking Academy right in the
7rs I've got videos that are over 10
years old that are still getting views
so what time did I upload that video who
cares was it 6 a.m or was it 3 P.M was
it Monday or was it Saturday it's 10
years old it's still getting views
YouTube Done Right really doesn't matter
the time you upload saying that it's not
smart YouTube eventually will show you
not when you start the channel but
eventually shows you when most of your
subscribers are online so it's
intelligent to be thoughtful about when
the video goes out so that it'll reach
the peak audience get some momentum
early on that could be part of getting
it ranked or suggested so just those
types of things it's that whole launch
strategy one of the visual illustrations
of the 7rs is some rocket ship imagery
you picture reverse Engineers like
charting the flight path where are we
even going like okay we're gonna we're
gonna go we're gonna do another moon
landing okay so we're going to the Moon
let's do some research what's what's the
weather like what's rotation of the
earth like are we ready what do we need
to do where's our technology now and
then let's actually launch you know and
then release and then the skipping ahead
will come back is then eventually rock
it by this point yeah you know record
would maybe be getting the rocket ready
release is optimizing those final
details and the reason we use that
imagery inside of video ranking Academy
is because in YouTube analytics for
anyone who's published a video before
you have this little blue line you have
uh this it's it's a launch and it goes
up and what we don't want to see is we
don't want to see it just launch and go
flat right uh we don't want to see it
launch and crash but and the dream is
that it would launch and go straight up
and never stop like just viral video
it'd just be launching straight up and
so release would be preparing for launch
preparing for the fight when you know
you're done when you finally make the
video public and you're presenting it's
packaging and presentation thumbnail top
or thumbnail title so now we're ready
for launch and then we hit the next R
let's blast off so real quick on release
one of the cool things that I love about
video ranking Academy and for someone
who's brand new to this and they're like
what is ranking it's basically when
someone searches for you know I have
some editing video so how to edit in
Final Cut Pro I'm at the top of YouTube
and there's like thousands of people uh
maybe tens hundreds I don't know
thousands of people a month searching
for this and that's really really
powerful and that sends a lot of traffic
a lot of views to to your business to
your YouTube channel yeah and so it's
really powerful one of the cool things
that I love about YouTube is that gets
people watching your video and then it
can help the algorithm actually start to
now put that in suggested and browse so
you're showing up on home page and we
found that uh just under 50 of our
viewers on think media in 2022 came from
search so we're still using search but
also YouTube is now recommending our
content to the right people which is
which is awesome so if you do it right
it's kind of like a perfect storm my
question though is today is ranking is
it harder to rank is it easier to rank I
know there's a freshness Factor can you
can you just talk about like what a lot
of people say like ranking's dead yeah
like you'll hear YouTube Educators they
don't talk about ranking videos yeah
it's like they don't even talk about it
and they're like you shouldn't be doing
that you should not be growing your
channels ranking I strongly disagree
with that I'd love to know your thoughts
yeah a couple things well one our think
media current definition of ranking
would be this it's videos
that continue to be to get views from
either being found in search or from
being suggested
so it's if you do this properly you can
tap into both traffic sources and I am
or one or the other and in either case
I'm cool with that if I just get views
six months from now 12 months from now
or 10 years from now then I'm happy
right and so rank I also it's kind of
old school SEO search engine
optimization
you could call it search based content I
think our modern definition of this kind
of content in VRA though is intent based
content because someone is searching
because they know the words to type in
or they're searching with just their
behavior they're wanting to get in shape
in January so they're on YouTube looking
for health related content but they
don't know what to look for so YouTube
begins to recommend them content what
you do on Google what you type into
Google what you click on Google you're
logged into your YouTube account when
you're on Google because Google owns
YouTube so your Google activity
influences your YouTube recommendations
because Google is just like okay we want
to satisfy this individual and if
they've been searching for this or
they're searching for that all of that
data can be used to try to surface
content that they'll love so under this
guy goes all the way back to reverse
engineering research that the to the
degree you understand the psychology of
the viewer you want to reach and what
they're searching for so that's thing
one I think thing two is while it's true
that suggested is the greatest form of
traffic YouTube is still the second
largest search engine in the world it's
70 of people go to YouTube wanting to
solve a specific problem and the reason
a lot of conflict develops here is just
because somebody that has a pure
entertainment mindset like Orion Trahan
Eric Mr Beast mindset goes well Mr Beast
isn't ranking videos about headphone
amplifiers and you're like yeah dude
respect the game there's so much
diversity on YouTube that is huge it's
massive there's yeah that's one type of
content whereas there's this whole other
opportunity and then where people really
make a mistake of being overly
judgmental is they don't understand the
economics they think if you're not
getting a million views or have a
million subscribers that you're broke
when in fact some of the wealthiest or
most successful YouTube creators are
business-minded entrepreneurs and
creators that have lower views or
smaller audiences but multiple flows of
income and so a search video up very
practically you using the headphone
amplifier analogy so I'm getting kind of
back I've always been super into music I
DJ'd in high school I had some
turntables vinyl records EDM underground
hip hop hip hop and uh these days I've
been getting back into audio file type
of things so This World includes
outrageously priced headphones it
includes Dax digital to analog
converters because of how good can that
so if you if you download title the
music service you can have high-res
audio files mqa audio files you can have
Dax that turn they take those digital
compressed files they make them sound
amazing and analog you have a headphone
amplifier which may be two devices and
on the low end a lot of times you'd
spend 500 to a thousand dollars on these
on these types of items and on the high
end there's four to six thousand dollar
headphones there's one to two three four
five thousand dollar Dax but they're
gonna say that blows my mind there could
be 5000 or headphone amplifiers and
you're like how much power and and when
you're in this Niche there's people also
that are buying multiples of things
right and so just like people
view us this way think media as for
cameras and whatnot I start looking into
the
um lcdx versus HiFi man you know I'm
gonna pretend I know what he's talking
about and the punchline is I'm looking
at versus videos I'm trying to decide
planar magnetic versus you know
traditional headphones and so again all
these some of these channels are getting
45 000 views 180 000 views on these
different headphone comparison videos
review videos and I am
knowledgeable because your mind's being
blown but I have no idea what I'm
talking about I need a Nolan in my life
I need an Omar in my life related to
these headphones if if this is your
thing and what about this I'm like oh my
gosh you just saved me yeah and again
they have affiliate links they've got
brand deals happening they've got
different stuff and so there's just so
much diversity on YouTube and so when
you talk about ranked
a couple things have been there's this
is this sums up the whole deal as I've
been going down this path again I am
typing certain things in search I'll
learn about a product topping headphone
amps and Dax compared to
that's the brand name
SC okay h i t t
amplifiers man are they just are they
kind of crappy though no they're they're
the No No amplifiers uh the first time
on this podcast man the most cursing
you've ever heard from these are just
brand names and book titles But
ultimately uh what's super funny about
that is is again so I'm typing those
things in but now YouTube what's YouTube
doing recommending me exactly it sees
that I'm into the audiophile thing and
that rabbit hole goes so deep so I'm
getting recommended creators I'm
describing craters I'm finding creators
I'm building trust with them because I'm
watching one or two videos that are
being recommended now I'm following them
on Twitter because Affinity is being
built that's what we're talking about in
this whole thing so that's all ranking
and it's it's different than you know I
flew across the country to give Mr Beast
a penny like it's just a whole different
different game it's a totally different
game it's super powerful for someone who
it already has a business yeah but
what's cool is it's also super powerful
for someone who wants to make YouTube
their job full-time living and and
that's why we're so pumped in our VRA
community and we have so many students
that are reporting because when you get
all of these things lined up this goes
back to picking reverse engineering the
right Topic in alignment like is the
audio file by the way I would say
there's unlimited opportunity saturation
is a myth it is a subculture of
passionate people that are all different
levels of economic status some people
want to get in there and they literally
have 500 budget right similar to Tech
500 they're trying to take 500 bucks
accessorize their smartphone similar
similar to our content to start creating
content and then there's somebody that's
like I just wanna entrepreneurs that
work with us they're like I just want to
ball out I want everyone that's not the
best thing the best yeah I want the Sony
cameras the best lights I want to build
the set build the studio there's a big
range but what you're also doing there
is back to the business plan your time
tapping into a subculture a market if
you went to a banker and you said there
is these Hi-Fi conferences that's a good
sign that you're in a good Niche if
there's Gatherings of people that go and
listen all these other headphones and
what's also funny is some some people
call it snake oil because at what point
what is the law of diminishing returns
if you're spending twenty five thousand
dollars on your headphones amp and deck
is it that much better and that much
better than my free Apple headphones
yeah 100 and so but but people people
love it and so if if you were passionate
about that that's also profitable and
you can rank all day long and you of
course they're going to take work you
stick with that thing a couple years
later you're also doing something you
love brands are probably sending you
free headphones you're getting
sponsorships and you've built a business
around your passion that you're having a
ton of fun you're definitely working
really hard a lot of money's coming in
as the years stack up and that's the
dream that's what we're helping people
do that's amazing so uh back to the 7R
framework we go from release to Rocket
can you explain uh I I know you touched
a little bit about rocket can you
explain that a little bit more yeah so
this again to that visual now imagine
it's finally time for liftoff anybody
listening to this that has made a video
public feels the emotions there's
there's nothing like making a video
confetti in the YouTube yeah it's Blast
Off time and there's there's every time
there's always that feeling a video goes
public the new video is released how's
it going to do you're watching it it's
like everybody's standing in air traffic
control biting their teeth you know
looking is this launch gonna be
successful or is it gonna Crash and Burn
and the truth about rocket is that if
you've done the first four r's well
you actually should be able to take a
step back and the video should take a
life of its own take on a life of its
own so not that you're passive at this
point but it doing number five well
would be number five you know video
taking off should be verification that
you reverse engineered well you research
well you recorded well and made a great
video You released it properly optimize
it properly what you can do and people
might say well I'm starting at scratch I
have zero views what this also includes
is this could include promoting the
video on internal YouTube features and
then also on external social media
platforms or places of influence so it's
anything you could do to add fuel to it
and so I got a good hack for this too
that we just shared in our YouTube
challenge and we'll leave a link in the
description if you guys want to join the
next one but and I just read a Facebook
comment because I logged into the into
the group the Facebook group that
everyone was in and I shared the shorts
remix and this is something I utilized
with my brand new Channel and I was
getting a couple thousand views on these
YouTube shorts and uh and basically what
you can do is on your content you can
clip from your long form video into a
short and what's cool is I just was
teaching in the challenge more in depth
how to do this and uh this lady there
was a ton of comments but this lady I
just logged in and the first comment was
like I tried the tip I tried the remix
and my first shorts you know didn't do
so well got like 87 views but then I did
it again on a different video it got 2
000 views next one got three thousand
the other one got two thousand and I'm
like that is adding fuel to the fire
that is one of those new features that I
think is so underrated that if you don't
you're not good at editing you don't
really have like uh just a lot of time
start remixing some of your long-form
content into shorts especially right now
with how really shorts are getting
rocketed in the YouTube algorithm
because they're pushing that are there
any other strategies like that that you
would add that like
um you know Community posts or just
different different tactics that can
help get the momentum going on YouTube
yeah and if you're starting at zero you
don't have some of the YouTube features
but if your channel is established
Community tab is one YouTube stories is
one Community tab even for older videos
you have new subscribers so there's
people who really probably don't know
about your videos from six months or 12
months ago but they just subscribed in
the last month our friend Neil Patel has
a good size email list so if somebody's
built an email list or they have a
customer list business owner service
providers sending an email to your list
with your latest video would be a way to
Rocket the video with external traffic
of people that care and then different
ways you could share on social media
um you know we do go deeper into this in
video ranking Academy and there's some
crazy case studies of
um different ways of doing this in Niche
communities and whatnot
um I would and and shorts and remixing
shorts is a whole other opportunity it
gets into even the idea of kind of
repurposing your content which we've
added on to you may other ways to
amplify content you've already created
and one of the things that we actually
have in the bundle right now with the
special offer for our podcast of
vrapodcast.com is our shorts master
class and so I know you're obsessed with
shorts I'm obsessed our whole team and
we are passing along some just amazing
information
um to get the word out there so yeah
there's a lot of different things you
could do there on that rocket R but
let's keep it moving to the final couple
yep so then the sixth step would be
review and uh explain what this is and
maybe I'd love to know where people are
kind of missing the mark on this step
and how they could do it better yeah so
I would I think that this is people's
kind of most people's least favorite
step maybe five percent of the
population is geeky and into analytics
I've developed the habit of falling in
love with them the quote we use here is
what gets measured gets improved
experience is not the best teacher
evaluated experience is the best teacher
so what people will do is they'll say
Sean Nolan I've posted 100 videos and
I'm just stuck that person has indicated
that they have a lot of experience but
what they are telling me is they're not
really evaluating that experience
because if you're if you've done 100
videos and nothing is changing then
you're really not learning from the last
one so this is saying that every time
you go around and this the vra7r
framework is you know there's a start
here launch and then it's a loop because
you just keep going through all seven
r's
on each video that you upload and so
it's not just post as many videos and
then get on the next one without taking
the time to analyze what went well what
didn't go well and then more
specifically actually taking the time to
really learn and master and understand
YouTube analytics I was hanging out with
my friend Michael Zuber from one rental
at a time who's made it almost to 50 000
Subs almost a million views a year we
did we actually analyzed we audited his
analytics live and he made almost 100
Grand on YouTube this last year he's a
real estate guy and a pretty cool
Channel if you're into like Niche real
estate event investing in finance stuff
but he said Sean I've like never looked
at my Analytics
and when I do I don't even know what I'm
looking at so I think that's the
intimidation Point here is it's kind of
overwhelming it's numbers graphs charts
what do they all mean what does the
terminology mean and that's also why
even though a podcast like this exists
where we try to give away as much free
information valuable information while
the necessity of a program like video
record Academy is so important because
mastering the skill of YouTube
understanding and mastering the platform
is an uphill battle like there's just a
lot to learn and that's what we exist
for is to hold people's hand and help
them understand that because to the
degree that you can start seeing the
Matrix you know and decoding The Matrix
as you're studying videos now you can
make data-driven decisions so that your
next upload can be a little bit better
that's another key is we say get one
percent better with every upload but
that could also be subjective the only
way it's not subjective is if there's
you're actually measuring things for
example it's starting to look and study
your audience retention curves maybe
looking for
in your audience retention curves is
there any areas where attention dips is
there any areas where it really is clear
that you lost the viewer well by
studying that
you now can go and say I'm going to not
use language like that or do edits like
that or do whatever I did in that moment
that ultimately uh lost the viewers
Therefore your next video it's not
necessarily like a lighting chain like
trying to make your lighting one percent
better that could be helpful it's
actually content it doesn't matter as
much yeah because it's not it's the
retention graph yeah there's way more
the retention graphs like the game and
of course click-through rate but then as
you dive deeper you're seeing over time
what which videos did and and the one
thing I'd also encourage some people is
that the goal is not to get stuck on any
of these R's the goal is actually to
keep moving through them as quick as
possible
but the more times you go through the 7R
process the better and to your point you
mentioned a lot of people will get stuck
in reverse engineer and research and
they won't even get to record my goal is
reverse engineer research record you
know release rocket review repeat and do
it again and do it again and again and
again and again and spend each time on
each R going a little bit deeper each
time but don't get stuck on one when
you're just starting and you only have
like three uploads or one upload there's
not much to review you actually need a
level sure you could get some feedback
but where things get really interesting
is once you've uploaded 10 videos or 20
or 30 or 40 or 50 and once you've been
on YouTube for one two three or four
months because now you can start looking
at comparing
February to March comparing march to
April now you can start comparing 90-day
performance on YouTube versus the
previous 90 days so the level of review
now we're at think media comparing years
to other years right you know what I
mean we're comparing Seasons to other
seasons and so the the review gets
exciting and it gets more exciting once
you start learning it I hate I've hated
math and I it's not my favorite male on
the think media team loves math she's
thinking about starting a brand called
Mel knows math I don't know if she
really wants to but it just kind of
flows and she like studied neuroscience
and so that has nothing to do with this
conversation but ultimately uh I've
started to fall in love with numbers I
think falling in love with numbers
falling love falling in love with the
data falling in love with those details
that can actually really help you over
time and and it really is endless yeah I
think one mistake that I see a lot of
people make in this phase is when you
when you have enough videos I think
you'll need like four at this point on
your channel
um you get ranked and so when someone
releases it they usually just see if
it's one out of ten meaning that's the
best if it's a 10 out of 10 that means
it's performing the worst out of your
last 10 uploads yeah and I think a lot
of people
put way too much weight on that uh
that's all they're reviewing and what's
awesome with learning the entire video
ranking Academy system and really deep
diving into this framework is we have
videos that we Post 10 out of 10 and
we're okay with it because we did the
reverse engineer we know this is meant
to rank over time and we go back and
some of the videos that we released 10
out of 10 are our best performing videos
right now because they pull so much
search they pull so many views and
suggested and so I just want to
encourage uh people that there's many
reasons it could not perform well in
that first day but it's like give it
some time if you actually Implement
these things that we're teaching uh in
video ranking Academy it's like it will
do well over time and you'll get views
eventually and so don't don't spend too
much time you know stressing about that
that's a good point you know and it was
two years ago at vidsummit so you the
fake team was there you know Mark Kyle
this past year the Year previous Todd
bupri from YouTube the product manager
one of the things he said in his talk
was people
under value they're two into the first
day or week of YouTube uploads and there
may be two into the last ten and they
are undervaluing evergreen or even just
the longer lifespan it will consistently
see it that videos will pop at day 20
day 30 day 45 day 65. and that is a hard
that the reason that's hard is it's
patience because we're sitting there in
air traffic control looking at the
launch and like sometimes getting a
little too preoccupied by it you check
in all day long you're in your YouTube
studio app on your phone and you need to
get out of the atmosphere yeah and then
you got to give us some time now to
start drifting you know what I mean yeah
and really get away from just that day
one like we study we're freaking it's
okay it's compulsive I am guilty of this
you know you're checking in multiple
times a day how's the video doing and
sometimes the ranking changes it's one
out of ten it drops to four or it's 10
out of ten it drops it goes to five oh
what's happening can I rocket it more
and so people kind of sometimes over
emphasize the amount of anxiety they
attach to day one through day two three
and are undervaluating day 30 day 60 and
year two of a potential Youtube upload
which is when you really start the more
you understand review and the longer
time Horizon you have to study it just
teaches you things where you know we
talked to Omar on a previous podcasts
we're like bro how do you feel if a
video gets 10 out of 10 he was like
unshakable he was like because I like
that metric when you know the intent of
the video when it was reverse engineered
properly research properly you're not
shaken by the vanity metric hoping to
get some serotonin and some dopamine off
the initial views to kind of stroke your
ego you're like I'm playing such a long
game here I know what I'm doing and I
think that's the confidence that video
ranking Academy gives you because of our
experience yeah our experience and our
practical approach to YouTube and so you
know you have guys like Omar you me like
we can tell you like chill out you know
10 out of 10 like give it some time and
even people just getting started on
YouTube the reason they actually stop
posting and they just give up on the
channel is because they don't see
results right away and I'm like that's
not even how YouTube works and so
because we know how it works that's the
power I think of just partnering up with
people who have seen it they've done it
and you know we
um we've just seen so many people come
through video Incan Academy and work
with us that it's like it's it still
works it works for them and um man we
have countless testimonies after
testimonies and so I just want to
encourage people too don't give up like
just keep going it might be a slow start
but if you just keep going you don't
give up you're gonna see the fruit of
that and uh that's what I love is this
this actually sets you up to not be in
the rat race of trying and trying and
trying and never seeing it any success
it's like let's get you doing the right
things and then try try and and it it'll
uh it'll start working for you and so I
love that we've been able to help so
many people well I think we should
probably hit the seventh R and not even
just take too much time on it because
honestly the seventh R has number one
been updated and number two there's just
more than we have time for here but the
seventh R is repeat yes and uh
the first part of repeat because it's
actually we technically have an athar
now so repeat is also now that I've done
all of this and I've reviewed how can I
begin again more intelligently could I
double down and should I make a part two
if I've identified that this video was
successful should I follow up is there
any comments on this video now that I
give it some time that indicate I should
answer a sequential question or make a
sequel to the video can I start learning
skills of batch producing is it a new
year I've done the 2022 version can I do
the 2023 version can I do the 2024
version all of those types of questions
um but the Aether Nolan is repurpose
because repeat is also asking
do I have to reinvent everything or can
I repurpose this we are making a video
podcast at this very moment can we chop
this into smaller Clips can we chop this
into shorts
um we I would argue that remix is a
repurpose activity you've made a video
how can you multiply the effect of that
video by repurposing it and remix is one
of those features and I want to give
some caution here
but
also once I Believe YouTube is your home
base that's what all the data tells us
it's the most profitable platform it's
the best healthiest platform but it's
not that you shouldn't also expand onto
other social media platforms as you keep
going through the 7rs money starts
coming in you're Building Systems repeat
would ask what systems can I build
around my YouTube channel to increase
sanity and make this more sustainable
and how can I repurpose some of my
YouTube content onto other social media
platforms especially with vertical video
because if we're making longer form
content like this we could chop it up
and not just upload YouTube shorts but
that vertical video could go a lot of
places so literally the seventh R can
expand into an entire Empire
of Internet domination of building your
brand multiple places and of course
having all of that strategy and thinking
is predicated on your vision predicated
on your goals predicated on your
resources what are you after for certain
business owners that is a big
opportunity I think about Anton stetner
who's a real estate investor and agent
in the Snohomish County Pacific
Northwest region his game is 100 YouTube
shorts right now but the vertical videos
he's creating for YouTube shorts he's
using a lot of other places and for what
he's trying to do that is the perfect
model for him so he can use the video
raking Academy system and not only crush
it with what he's doing but also be
expanded and what's actually interesting
is on every single social media platform
you should reverse engineer you should
research your video ideas you should
record a great video even if it's 60
seconds it is vertical you should
optimize it properly for that platform
and release it properly it should rock
it but can you share it can you collab
with somebody on Instagram you should
review the insights and analytics on the
other platforms you should study and
repeat so actually we've learned that
this framework and system is so powerful
of course I'm biased but the best
investment anybody listening to this can
make in their business their brand their
future their skill sets is to learn this
7R system it's been so refined and
worked on and it benefits people far
beyond YouTube starting on YouTube is
the most intelligent strategy I believe
because when you expand from there
you're just killing multiple birds with
one stone you're getting a return on
your energy and you're multiplying your
income streams how can I even start
again and create more lucrative
opportunities in the future so inside
the program we go really deep on that
and we could continue to go deeper on
this whole repurpose R because that's a
whole thing in and of itself